sometimes I don't even check what it is
or the title and I click and it'll just
be like ooh lesbian C okay and then like
what's going on here and then oh it's
not a lesbian scene one of the girls has
a penis
[Music]
welcome back to one of the most
Monumental important episodes of the
careful boys ever
this is the hot seat episode featuring
Jojo
uh I have to say that I feel so bad for
all of our guests sitting here because
this [ __ ] chair sucks bro with the
Apple box it's a launcher look I got my
feet they like taika it's like when you
go to the barber as a kid yeah yeah I'm
like no wonder people are like leaning
and this [ __ ] like looks like it's gonna
break don't lean too much I think it
will flip it they will but that's the
best part is that we we lecture them
like don't leave too much don't leave
this jig it's like what do you do all
right it's their fault so if you guys
watched the video before where we
discussed Joe's Hot Seat questions and
he wasn't here Joe has not watched this
he did not watch it they told me
specifically wait for your hot seat
because when it came out I was excited I
was like oh [ __ ] what should I do we do
that video like months ago and Hannah
almost told me she was like oh you want
to know I'm like no no no they told me I
can't find out so I was like it'll be
fun to do the video and then watch
afterwards yeah what a good sport yeah
of course I mean that's what makes good
entertainment though very true very true
as tradition goes Bart is going to start
off with the coldest question this one
is not a predetermined why is so
disappointed because this is when people
tune out no no no no this is the most
the best thing to start the whole video
with for sure hopefully it's better than
Nikki are you stuck in a mango and
Nikki's gotta go micro body like well
what kind of mango is it like a big
mango this is way better this is way
better
Hey Joe
if you had to redesign the hand how many
fingers would you have six easily why
because the opposable thumb helps with
the grip but sometimes I wish I had
another opposable thumb on this side oh
for even more grip dripping what
jacking off oh it's not even gripping
what it's like a totally action you
wanted that icon because this one said
jacking off so imagine it's like this
and then this one tickles your tank let
me check whoa that's pretty legit that's
pretty legit damn that's pretty good
though like that imagine if you had a
hand like this I feel like I've heard
you talk oh wait so it would be another
thumb though right yeah because you
wouldn't want two thumbs up yeah it's
like imagine a hand like this one right
here that's a funny hand dude
that's the most best hand I've ever seen
yeah I can't imagine a better ad you're
like hey can I get the number three it
could be like this or you could like get
the number three like that or if you're
German that's exactly why it's more
useful Bart
all right um starting with some of the
questions that we
pre-selected all right what's the last
movie you saw two times
two times oh that's [ __ ] good does it
count if you saw it like one and a half
one like almost 75 and then you're like
oh [ __ ] I gotta watch it again to finish
the 25 no not too full time two
full-time I think it's a pretty simple
question
how the [ __ ] do you know
no don't [ __ ] remember
what about Indiana Jones
just said this [ __ ] I listened Oh I
thought you meant back to back I
see you more than
more than Joe we we've come to
understand that you normally only watch
movies once yes and then you want to be
a movie writer no no the thing is I want
to watch it once forget it uh I don't
want to know what's gonna happen next
that's fair let me forget it and then
watch it from a different lens okay what
is if I'm sitting there predicting
everything and I'm like oh it's not that
fun anymore
is there a movie that you watched for
the second time recently oh yeah like
all my childhood movies I'm going
through them oh you're doing that that's
why I did the uh Indiana Jones
um I got to do the Back to the Future
series those are movies that I would
watch multiple times nice but you
haven't
uh that's gonna be my next after I'm I
just finished Indiana Jones so you have
it have you watched Back to the Future
I've watched it over like 20 times okay
do you get mad at yourself when you can
predict what's like why do you know
what's gonna happen don't know yeah I
want to be surprised
um I want to forget it so much too I'm
like wow the boulder this is the scene
that happens uh another question I don't
know how we thought of this was uh can
we read your recent text to the group
chat whatever that is yeah tell me what
I wrote yeah
it just says okay let me see if they can
get that sorted before our next shoot oh
oh that was the mic oh that's logistical
careful Boy chat oh wait no actually the
last thing you sent was long 10 Cafe
that's the real one what was the motive
behind that was it like
long tank Cafe no no like like the [ __ ]
that I say in a group chat yeah we just
wanted to see by then you might have
said something so insane that would have
been funny but okay I got one all right
all right WTF
because sometimes they are they are
Happy Thanksgiving guys I look forward
to every time we have our talkathathons
and appreciate you because I think
sometimes we're really funny and then
sometimes like the whole conversation is
going one way and it's just something
really random yeah from Joe like Joe
like posts is like a [ __ ] random link
where like this is nothing to do with
what we're talking about yeah basically
all right conversation yeah exactly
we're just in text form but that's why
he's pure and genuine yeah what's what's
the most recent porn you busted a nut to
oh man
um don't need my phone over there throw
me my it's on it's like bookmarked no I
can see my history oh hey look this is
Corporate Joe here we go maybe we can do
a short lunch too so we can get more
articles in
classic you know how much we need the
lunch to eat and get sustenance yeah um
the title is
I.T specialist picks up Ukrainian Beauty
and [ __ ] her
oh
[ __ ] wow and which thing did you type
the Ukrainian the I.T I I type the I
look at the pictures yeah and I've
gotten in trouble so many times as you
guys know on the show like there
sometimes I don't even check what it is
or the title and I click and it'll just
be like ooh lesbian C okay you know oh
there's a threesome there's another guy
and then like oh what's going on here
and then oh it's not a lesbian scene one
of the girls has a penis oh but that's
okay what's gonna happen now and then he
grabs her and starts sucking the [ __ ]
out of it I'm like Ah that's not what I
bargained for
is this last one is it uh did you jack
to it or did you bust to it that's the
last one I bust to it and what I do now
these days which part yeah when he when
he grabbed her and started sucking it is
that what he busted
I try to time it yeah with the guy it's
more intimate okay I think everyone does
you try to time it at the same time but
sometimes it's just too intense and you
just release and then I feel guilty
because I couldn't meet my goals do you
keep skipping past the girl part so you
can get the guy you know where to come
the taint shop and then you leave them
hanging because you end it early What's
um if you had to rehire
if you had to rehire I'll fire you guys
first an X from JK which one would it be
oh [ __ ]
X girlfriend or X how many
ex-girlfriends are there just I don't
know I'm just throwing them x x member
because if there's not a lot of
ex-girlfriends and yeah ex members just
remember yeah there's one guy
that I was really curious of how things
would turn out if he stayed with us huh
and I can't really disclose his name
because because you know I want to
protect his identity because I do like
him okay but he was a [ __ ] klepto and
we told this story with this guy [ __ ]
back in the day oh save it though we
would be losing [ __ ] right
and then we're just like man we're so
forgetful aren't we Bart yeah we're so
[ __ ] mindless here and then we're
like oh we lost this lens and he goes oh
I got the same one I'll let you guys
borrow it and we're like oh [ __ ] for
real hey you're so nice man I bring it
over here and then like we would keep
losing [ __ ] and you would keep letting
us borrow things that we lost right and
then one day
but the thought keep in mind it's also
during the time where it's like there's
only V1 camera everyone used okay so
like right now like there's so much [ __ ]
now that every every Studio has
different [ __ ] it was like ever it's
like the Canon
um 5D Mark II Arrow everyone had that
one thing so it was like with the 2470
ones yeah everyone that showed up had
that gear so I was like all right yeah I
could see it's weird that it's so
coincidental but everyone has this it's
like everyone has rolled mics yeah
everyone has [ __ ] sure smbs for a
[ __ ] podcasts yeah yeah it's the same
[ __ ] right um
so one day
um my my ex the girl I was living with
at the time she found an iPhone from
school she picked up she goes oh I
should find their owner right and we're
filming so she's like oh let me get out
of the way she left it on the counter
and then she walked away and then Geo
saw that
she just put it on the counter and it's
gone and she looked up and she saw the
intern like [ __ ] waddling to the car
like this she goes He took it into me
about like oh [ __ ] so we [ __ ] boned
out there we ran over there right we're
like hey dude
um oh before that he opens his car
throws something in and closes it real
quick and we're like hey dude um
did you just take the iPhone he goes
what no I do not oh and keep in mind
like Jill had her eyes on him because
when he was around he would not like she
would notice like when she leaves her
desk go use the bathroom like when he
comes back
like the laptop will be flipped over so
she'll like purposely do things through
her items oh just his chest and then
when she comes back it's the other way
and then she's like Okay so this guy
fumbles through things
yeah yeah do you think Geo's planting
iPhones yeah so you liked him well
here's let me get to the part where so
everybody's still confused Joe doesn't
hire for talent if you haven't found out
oh we found out that way you son of a
[ __ ] we took a hard look at the mirror
I'm doing his face he's talented in many
ways so um so we go confront what'd you
say it like that yeah like he jerked you
off like he's touching his throat you
can suck your penis and then this guy
goes
I feel so uncomfortable right now I'm
gonna anxiety attack that you you would
accuse me with such a thing and we're
like oh it's cool like it's not a big
deal we just want to see we talked to
him so chill too yeah and he goes off
the show you everything if that's what
you want to see and he popped out his
[ __ ] trunk and then we're like nah we
saw you close the back door to you see
there's a it's in the back seat and I
think at the same time too I had like a
TV with a VCR set and stuff and I just
gave it to him that same day so he had
that in the back and then all this stuff
he's got Julia tied up blindfolded
he's like see I look at all this [ __ ]
you gave me this [ __ ]
we were
you know what a kid is trying to reveal
like that they're innocent it was like
that because we came out and we're like
hey we hate to do this to you but we'd
have been having things missing and this
is the last recent thing that's missing
we're gonna check everyone can we check
you first you want to check sure I'll
show you everything and he's opening all
the doors except for the one that we
asked oh can you open the trunk he's
like oh you can't talk anything open the
back door oh you want to see oh you
wanna see him in the trunk [ __ ] look at
my pocket look look so he showed every
like his misdirections
are like oh can we see you he's amazing
so funny he's amazed well to me that was
so funny watching this dude sweat that I
was just it was it was weird it was like
it was like happy torture like you're
laughing at this guy in your heart
because we thought we're gonna whoop his
ass you know and then we're like okay
this is this is really this guy's
killing himself yeah so but we had to
keep a straight face so I was just like
hey dude so you got a couple options
it's like one you know you just
peacefully just let us see it give us
give it back to us you know to
um we'll beat your ass oh [ __ ] what we
call the cops and handle it legally if
you feel threatened if you feel like you
need the cops to be here and you want to
do it that way we have three options and
then he's all like okay okay I'll just
show you everything and then he starts
going through opening all the stuff that
it's obviously not there and we're like
no we want to see the back seat and he
goes oh I'm having a panic attack I
can't stand anymore and he sits down
right and he goes oh I can't breathe
right and in the moment we're like dude
like what do you want to do he goes I
just need a moment in this [ __ ] bird
shits on him no way like a [ __ ] movie
because he sits his car was parked on
the street he walks down like underneath
with like the telephone or like the the
street light is he sits I just need a
[ __ ] moment and it's literally like
the timing was like yeah like that and
we were like dude God is telling your
ass right now that's wild dude and we
were just looking at each other like I
can't believe this is happening so
[ __ ] funny yeah and then like I don't
know so after that you know he went home
he's all like he called me a meeting he
goes you wouldn't believe what happened
I'm like what happened dude he goes a
bird [ __ ] on me no he goes the iPhone
was in the VCR I don't know how it got
in there
in the VCR in his car how did that
happen the VCR that Joe gave him he's
like maybe when I blindfolded Julia she
put it in
this guy stole her lands and everything
because he matched the serial number to
the box and everything we're like dude
it's you just bring it back I have to
say can I say what a generous thief the
fact that he's still [ __ ] for me is like
oh you guys use your [ __ ] I'm sorry
that's kind of different but so what's
the [ __ ] upside again like so okay so
the upside is so that's who Joe wants to
bring back why would you want to bring
it back
he was one of our best interns like he
was very attentive doesn't yeah to steal
[ __ ] he's trying to steal he's like tons
of detail so every single like we would
have a hot seat like I mean like like
hot shoot like it's really hot
everyone's [ __ ] dripping and sweat
and then he's like everyone's getting
exhausted but this dude is running over
patting people on the forehead like Bart
you're sweating do you need water and
like he's there meanwhile he's got the
AC unit in his car you're sweating
you're sweating he's like
but not only that silly Parts
because he's he's like one of the you
know when people that are like good at a
job when they come in they just kind of
like fill all the roles and like all the
in-betweens right so he's the kind of
guy that's like
um like we do the bare minimum roll roll
roll like he'll probably wipe all three
lenses every single time yeah why Blood
doesn't even take them yeah probably
like but he I don't know guys like if he
sees something being repeated he adds an
efficiency to that so that it's smoother
the next time the next time the next
time okay so that's so that's one point
but the other point is my entertainment
like when I saw this guy crumble I
thought that was so funny and I wanted
to repeat that over and over so I wanted
him to steal so I could catch him steal
more [ __ ] because catching people in the
ACT it's like it's like Chris Hansen
right like it's like it's like people
[ __ ] [ __ ] and it's okay I think it's
so funny can I have some pizza that guy
is the [ __ ] best but yeah it was that
can I in the slice right now
so okay how about this one now that it's
a 16 minute 18 seconds oh we're at least
doing 40 minutes
get a little more personal
um I'll miss my flight I don't want to
be here but I'll be here for this yeah
this is good what's your love language
and what do you think Hannah's is oh
okay so
um great question both of us is
definitely acts of service because of
the way we both work uh grew up
um I'm getting better at
words of affirmation okay so but I think
all women have a
that's very important still like no
matter what culture like it's very
important to like constantly remind them
because it's like man I [ __ ] worked
hard to be with you but I still gotta
tell you and for like you forget or what
they do forget right yeah
um acts of service uh and quality time
you know that's a pretty big one for me
um
because I've noticed over the years the
things that I thought I was I'm oh man
all I need is [ __ ] access service
that's all I need but then I'm like oh
no that's what I thought I needed but in
reality like I'm always going on
adventures with her and [ __ ] and it's
[ __ ] hilarious it's awesome and I was
like but that's a part of my
relationships that I always liked like
it's the it's the friend aspect yeah and
hers is the same as you you said I think
hers is similar to me but
um and expressed differently so like
acts of service to me might be like yo
thanks for like helping like being
thoughtful and like you knew I didn't
have time to do this but you helped me
finish it up but like it's a task
hers might be like
um it's thoughtful because
um I heard that like you know
from maybe she was on the phone and she
goes oh I like doing this thing and I
was like I heard it and I'm like okay
maybe I'll I'll do that for the next
time or something
yeah I have never heard you say a bad
thing about Hannah
is that some kind of [ __ ] or
um have you maybe found someone who is
more to your love language like like 100
yeah I feel completely understood for
you know that's [ __ ] awesome yeah for
the first time in my life but didn't I
break you up from your ex and like I had
a malicious reason for doing so you son
of a [ __ ] Steve you [ __ ] took me
away God damn right the chair dude
um so do you subscribe to Steve Green
Theory now or or
um I always knew you were against me and
trying to ruin me but I'm not gonna let
you take me down
I'll never let no it's
it's um
it's one of those things where you don't
know what you're missing until you
encounter this type of relationship and
then you go oh so this is how it's
that this is how it's like when two
people that get like get along and they
see the world the same way like kind of
come together it's like oh okay that
that makes sense and if you're around a
world where um you know everyone's in a
dysfunctional relationship in your
family or whatever you don't have a good
example then you think that is normal
yes you do yeah and then so you don't if
you don't have good Role Models like and
also if your peers are going through the
same kind of like workout yeah like
they're just working out their
differences and like it's normal
relationships is suffering it's like you
take your finger put in the pinprick and
it [ __ ] hurts it's like uh what the
[ __ ] are you guys talking about yeah I
went through that before no it's not
like that it shouldn't be like that but
I do think the majority of the world
thinks that's normal because that's what
everyone does yeah so so if that's the
majority then you think oh okay then
that's it and then so um one thing that
surprised me about uh this relationship
is how easy it is like I thought they
would be more
differences like we do fight but it's a
it's a different kind of fight yeah with
gloves on it's bickering it's bicker
yeah it's a lot of I'ma kill you you
know what's
um the number one way that you feel
Hannah has made you a better person
all right don't rage and I'm just
kidding I still rage nice kidding
um
I'm confused right now
damn dude a better person
if she hasn't you can say she hasn't
can I can I step in yeah what do You
observe her yeah no so as a Joe Observer
and a fan I I love you but um I think
honestly your breakup made you a better
person and I think you were because
thanks to you right no no no no no no no
no no no no truly like you learned
enough about yourself through the
previous relationship to take the tools
into the next relationship yeah and then
it was like a love language match so
then now you're like [ __ ] clicking on
all cylinders because you had all that
but like I don't think you would have
had that if you were just chilling in
the last one it's definitely Stepping
Stones right like people shouldn't
really look at all their past
relationships as failures but like
different
kind of Parts where you can see
different aspects of yourself and if you
can grow from that to the next point
then I think you get ready for that
Palmer and mature that way so like I
don't know if uh
she is like oh now I'm with the right
one so like now it's like the best it's
not really like that yeah I think I
think to back up what Steve is saying I
think it's like a stepping stone to you
know being ready for that person yeah
100 and I've seen it that's what's so
cool I [ __ ] have seen it it's all
it's it's really awesome just as ear bud
I've I love seeing it but but the
coolest thing too also about Hannah is
that she can hang dude like with anybody
like you bring her to all of us she's
not intimidated at all she has military
Brothers they're scarier than we'll ever
be even like me and Anthony doing
[ __ ] 100 push-ups each
it's pretty scary
he speaks my love language because he
said like this is what he said to her
she was like you know I still got
because you special forces and [ __ ] he
goes I still got that international
passport and like if anything happens
you know [ __ ] it I ain't afraid to use
it meaning he'll come over and kill me
himself and when I heard that I was like
dude this guy loves you you have a great
family
and because that's my mentality of like
this is a dedicated brother because
that's an act of service he'll
commitment the service of quality time
but when most people hear that they'll
be like horrified like that's the kind
of brother you have yeah like why does
he want to [ __ ] hurt me so talk sir
but then for me I'm like oh dude this
guy you have a really down loving family
yeah yeah that is really cool this this
was a really good question and it was
Colleen who thought of it oh really but
um we were talking about you and Colleen
was
um basically expressing how just how
nice you are and a lot of people might
not know that but
um she wanted to know
do you feel that you received the same
quality of treatment that you give out
I don't expect the same quality of
treatment and that's because I think
long time ago I made the realization
that like what will happen is people
will be themselves regardless of how you
act and so like you could be as kind and
as giving but if you have this mentality
of like everything has to be
reciprocated because I'm giving it to
you then what will eventually happen is
that uh you'll feel like the world is
taking advantage of you and so I don't
like that mentality so for me I'm like
well I should also not be so uh not
self-righteous but like kind of like
holding people hostage of my good deeds
so I just know that hey I'm not getting
what I want out of this situation so
maybe this friendship is unbalanced or
this interaction is not really worth my
time and if you gauge every experience
this way then I think there might be
traits about people that you don't like
but you can keep them around
did you ever get stepped on a lot to
realize that or is that just something
that you've known inherently I don't
know
um but I do think like like kind of like
how me and bar grew up with uh
people that will so like if someone gave
us a death threat or something back in
the day like it was taken seriously
right it's not just comments or like if
you're if you're from a certain world
where like your sense of rules and
everything is different and then like
your own friend can turn on you or like
there's jail time and this is just a
more
Battleground kind of place and like real
consequences real consequences and and
in those situations when you have guys
that are like Gang Related or whatever
and they're still genuine nice people to
you I think you start to see like oh it
doesn't matter what a person does
there's like great qualities in
everybody and what matters is your
negotiation with this individual I think
so then I don't look at people in the
sense of like hey you're all scumbags
although it's funny to say that because
I always say that of course everyone's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] or Everyone's an idiot but
in reality I think like everyone's mixed
everyone's both God and the devil
everyone's got all kinds of weird
mixtures about them that were like yeah
you have likable traits you might be a
murderer but there might be some good
qualities about you too and as long as
you're not gonna kill me I think we can
have like a space but I I don't know so
I think kindness to me is like default I
think some people are just like
you have inherent traits right I don't
even see it as kind of it's just like I
just enjoy doing certain things like if
my love language is service or whatever
I just enjoy doing it and then I get the
joy out of like treating people out or
whatever and I don't feel like you now
you gotta do that to me you're not
logging it no but I do take note though
because like let's say I'll go dinner
with someone and I think it's [ __ ]
hilarious when you like kind of pay for
their meals and then they'll be like you
know what
you pay for so many meals so this time
we should pay half and half I think that
kind of [ __ ] is hilarious and that's
been done to me right so I take notes
about that [ __ ] because then it builds a
profile about who this person is you
better understand who they are so you
know along that [ __ ] not a lot of that
[ __ ] but I take notes I write it down
but I don't hold it against them I just
think it's funny yeah yeah and then like
I like
who they are so I so I let them be I
think what people do control like hey I
want you to be this way so then like if
you behave a certain way I gotta punish
you but for me I want you to be the
truest you so I can real really take
notes of what kind of a [ __ ] scumbag
or good person you are is there
something about you that you struggle to
communicate but you wish everyone knew
I think that's been my whole life of
feeling misunderstood and I think that's
why like with Hannah and everything I
have this autistic love person that
understands without even having to say a
lot of stuff right
so
um that helps a lot because I don't have
to say things and then she gets it
and throughout life like you know from
parents and family members and and
people of authority uh not understanding
what I'm saying but also me not being
able to articulate that's been a
lifelong acceptance of I just can't say
what's in here sometimes or maybe I'm
not versed I don't have enough words
um and so I've accepted that but I do
think that um
it's never just one statement or thing
that I want to get out like I might be
working on a thought or an idea or
whatever it is and
um I might just say conclusions or
fragments because I've already worked
out so much that it seems so simple and
then so I'll tie a conclusion together
and it's funny because when I look from
third person I'm like what the [ __ ] are
you saying you [ __ ] but then a lot of
times it makes a lot of sense
um and I I would like to have a more
flushed out journey of how to bring
people from A to Z on what I'm trying to
explain I asked that question because
because you remind me a lot of Nikki no
but really like super hot I just think
you have a great ass no
no but like the way that how sick of it
the earnestness that you approach
everything is so admirable like I tell
people all the time I'm like man I wish
you guys like if you got to meet Joe you
would know that the guy AI will be the
first if you're a new guest at JK he'll
be the first guy to like like you're
like oh you like this shirt cool let me
give it to you like you don't mean like
that's Joe right like that's the joke we
all know like if they're like they have
a problem with their car he's like oh my
God I have this car I'm like yeah here's
my guy [ __ ] go there he'll take care
of you like that's Joe so like I just
you know but you don't always come
across that way because like you're
sitting in this chair and you're [ __ ]
around too but but that that part of you
is your I think your biggest like that's
why you're a glittering gem to me but I
don't think that you always communicated
that way yeah or at least it's received
that way because of your communication
skills
um as far as representing yourself
yeah I think I think so I think there's
been a lot of
um misunderstanding like just labels
over the years of like oh you know you
don't you're not emotional you're not
connected or whatever it is right so
it's like I I'm I clearly observe what's
happening and I can see what's going on
and I am I I might not be able to
express it but I think the the
difference is the way that people go
into like the social role play like
let's say uh the way that you go up to a
cashier and say like hi uh I would like
to buy this and the cashier be like oh
how was your day right it's like a
script I don't go by that average script
in expressing oneself so then
when I see like I don't want to say
normal humans but most people they they
revert to a script that they were taught
like by watching movies or how for their
parents were yeah they there's like this
way of like oh this is what you're
supposed to say yeah right but then for
me it doesn't feel authentic so I don't
bother doing the thing that Society does
to express that thing so then because I
opted out of that completely then I
don't have the skill to uh do the thing
that everyone else is doing what they
expect yeah what you expect because it's
like oh when someone comes you're
supposed to do the polite thing to do
but then if I didn't grow up doing that
then I just like I just it goes over my
head yeah I don't know if that makes any
sense yeah last thing real quick just
curiosity when you're with Hannah I
remember I don't know the answer but I'm
really curious no but when you're with
Hannah like you know how when you get
home everybody knows this and like you
feel like you can just be yourself but
like if somebody else is there you have
to like pull it on yeah do you think you
have to do that right hand or no I don't
know how to put this in a it sounds bad
but it's almost like she's invisible
that's awesome that's so [ __ ] awesome
yeah but you know what I mean right it's
like it's like I can be myself yeah yeah
yeah and same with her she's like I'm an
introvert and I need to [ __ ] recharge
from all these people but she goes but
when I'm with you like I can fully
recharge do you ever say that to her
romantically like oh my God I love you
so much it's like you're invisible to me
like I'm trying to find a better way
this is the best way to put it honestly
no I know exactly but I've said it to
her before you're golden yeah I did say
that to her and it came off really wrong
because it was like it's almost like
you're not even there like you know what
I mean like
babe it's exactly what I want to do no
but that is so good because because that
is honestly probably the worst thing
about dating is like when you're there
you have to LARP that you're like you're
the best version of you yeah but if you
can get home and then relax and be
yourself and then it is like they're not
there but you're yourself they feel just
as comfortable as you do and that's
[ __ ] Kismet bro that's that's like
when everything's clicking on a hundred
and it's not only just being like let's
say in the past I've been myself right
but I'd be in trouble for being myself
exactly so I think that's the difference
is like what's just the dive into what
would be the thing that would get you in
trouble of you being yourself I don't
know any specific examples but I think
like
generally
okay so this is like kind of
exaggerating but you know how you hear
guys going like oh yeah when my girls
telling me like oh just tell me
everything and then you actually tell
them and they get mad at you like those
kind of situations it's like a [ __ ]
set up for it it's incompatibility but I
think it's just two people not
using the same words like this is one
Guru that I listened to his name is like
sag Guru and he said that
basically like conversation is a is is a
conspiracy between two people because
these two people have to agree on the
words
and what they mean because they can mean
two different things right so like if
this couple is like talking to each
other and they're like what do you mean
by [ __ ] that and then they get into a
fight and then it's happened in so many
of my past relationships because then
it's like the words that you're using
it's wrong to each other what do you
mean you want me to be invisible exactly
right and then they take it as an
offensive thing when you're trying to
express love right so I think that's
been the case in the past but like when
you're in a relationship where like like
where you kind of use the same verbiage
or whatever you just see the world the
same way then it's like
um you don't get in trouble for
expressing your thoughts and being who
you are because they know that where
it's coming from yeah they're giving you
the benefit of that so it's like they
know it's not malicious or whatever so
it creates this loving space where you
can have honest conversations and I
think that's really difficult to do for
most people yeah
um
this is just a question for me we don't
have to keep this in but like if um
would you rather [ __ ] your mom or your
dad yeah do you know the answer I'll
rail my dad all right and bust inside of
his ass [ __ ] your father-in-law or get
[ __ ] by your father oh my
father-in-law is [ __ ] probably way
more romantic my dad will [ __ ] aggro
[ __ ] me dude yeah yeah yeah my stepdad's
gonna be gentle dude he wants romance so
for so for having come in and like kind
of getting to know you better and also
getting to know
the drama that happened here before my
time I got to see kind of a whole other
side
and some facts that like kind of
exonerate a lot of [ __ ] that I've seen
said about you that were incorrect oh
thank you very much but why my question
is
why do you why don't you ever say
anything like there's so many things
that put so much [ __ ] to rest yeah you
just kind of go ah
I think um when I
so I'm very impulsive right I know that
about myself
but on the flip side
I can kind of predict probabilities of
what's probably going to happen if I act
toward this way so let's say someone
says something about me online right
and for me it's inevitable like there
yeah I could clear my name but it's a
high probability that this will just
continue drama which is never the reason
why I wanted to create and be online so
if I wanted to come here my goal was
just to make a fun space then I'm going
against the goal that I was gonna do
even if it means I can clear my name or
whatever that's not the goal that I set
to do if I if my mission was to come out
here and make like jokes and whatever
maybe some people will misunderstand or
maybe they'll make a decision and pass
judgment upon me without even knowing
the full story that's really on them so
it's not really on me to like sit here
and like fight the case because then the
focus will be about fighting the case
and how many other videos do I have to
create to defend and I think that was
the path that I never wanted to go down
and so unless things get extreme and
severe
um like let's say I'm I'm being a
accused of like a major crime like I'm a
Harvey Weinstein or some [ __ ] and I
really got to clear myself because no
one could watch my content with that in
the back of their minds then obviously
yeah that would hurt the the viewer
experience but for me no matter how big
the the drama might be I know that it'll
eventually pass because it seems big and
important but people have to realize
that no one gives a [ __ ] about me and
you like no one everyone [ __ ] gives a
[ __ ] about themselves right so this
moment it seems so intense but in
reality they're busy with their own
lives they might be going through a
breakup they might have a family member
that's dying like these numbers behind
the view there's human beings with their
own [ __ ] issues right so I'm like if
you look at the hundreds of thousands of
people out there that might be pissed or
whatever it's like
me I'm just a minute of their
entertainment and attention and it
doesn't [ __ ] matter but a lot that's
what I wish a lot of creators Knew Too
is like yeah you're important before the
moment like you have a bigger mission to
[ __ ] accomplish and do you really
want to make it about you like telling
everybody actually I'm right and they're
wrong and there's so many [ __ ] people
that get caught up in that and I hate it
and I think that's been one of the
biggest issues that I had is I hate that
about uh
people is like they're more concerned
about feeling right than being right so
like when you're so concerned about like
oh I want to be right and I want people
to feel like that my my rightness and I
want people to validate how good and
right I am and it's like then you're
missing this [ __ ] opportunity you
have a [ __ ] audience you have so many
things you could be doing like talking
about who would you rather [ __ ] your mom
or dad
by the way that's a great question which
is why we deserve a streaming yeah then
it's like why don't we just focus on
this like and this [ __ ] will pass let's
move on and then the strong Will Survive
and then for me that's that's really
what it's all about and I don't need to
also to Joe's defense though like uh and
we've done this off camera we've talked
about those similar things too it's like
sometimes even to exoner himself
um would have to mean like taking down
or talking [ __ ] about somebody else so
that like the fans actually know but
like you know Joe's time to time against
it like that's not the point he doesn't
want to do that either you know what I
mean so it's like you to witness you on
the more noble end you know and just
being like look it'll just pass and like
to choose not to like have to like
correct everybody out there who's
[ __ ] told that like hears one side of
the story and wants to comment about it
that's also like wow we're willing to
stick around just be like all right you
know we'll back them up too so cool cut
my pay let's go
punishing all the one
yeah
that was awesome thank you guys thank
you brother
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign